Problem 75.
Two airplanes left the same
airport traveling in opposite
directions.
If one plane averages 400 miles
per hour-- so this is
the airport.
One plane goes in that
direction at
400 miles per hour.
That's a mile not a meter.
And another plane averages
250 miles per hour.
And it's going in the
other direction.
And I do this as vectors.
So the length of the my
arrow represents its
speed to some degree.
And the direction represents
direction.
250 miles per hour in that
direction, 400 miles per hour
in that direction.
In how many hours will the
distance between the two
planes be 1625 miles?
So you just have to say, if
you're sitting in this plane
right here, this plane
to the left.
And you let's say you think
you're stationary.
How fast is that plane going to
be moving to the rightwards
direction, or I guess to
the eastward direction?
Well from your point of view,
it's going to be going in the
east direction at 650
miles per hour.
If you thought that you were
stationary, it would just be
going away from you at
650 miles per hour.
Same thing, if you were sitting
in this plane right
here, and you thought you were
stationary-- and you are,
relative to yourself-- you'd
say, oh, why this guy is going
to the west at 650 miles per
hour relative to me.
And we're starting at
the same point.
So this just becomes a standard
distance is equal to
rate times time problem.
So if we have to cover 1625
miles, because that's what
they want to know, when
does that happen?
At what point are the planes
that far from each other?
That is equal to their relative
velocity, they're
separating from each other
at 650 miles per hour.
And we want to know how long
is that going to take?
So time is going to equal
1625 divided by 650.
Let's see if we can simplify
that at all.
Well, we could divide the top
and the bottom by 25.
If we divide the top one-- let
me just get my calculator.
So 1625 divided by 650
is equal to 2.5.
And we were doing everything
in miles per hour.
So time is going to be
equal to 2.5 hours.
This choice is A.
Problem 76.
I'll just copy and paste all
these word problems. We'll
parse them together.
Problem 76 in green.
Lisa will make punch that is 25%
fruit by adding pure fruit
juice to a two liter mixture
that is 10% pure fruit juice.
How many liters of pure fruit
juice does she need to add?
Pure fruit juice.
So let P equal liters of pure.
And that's what they want
us to figure out.
So we have to figure out P.
All right.
And adding it to a two liter
mixture., So so let's say M is
equal to the liters
of the mixture.
That is 10% fruit juice.
So that is this right here, to
a two liter mixture, that is
10% fruit juice.
We're calling that M.
That is the two liter mixture
that is 10% fruit juice.
OK, how many liters of
pure fruit juice
does she need to add?
OK, so let's think about
it a little bit.
So, punch is going
to be pure juice.
So let's think about how much
pure juice is going to be in
the system.
The liters of pure juice
she adds, plus the
liters of the mixture.
Well it's a two liter mixture
that is 10% fruit juice.
So how much fruit juice
is already there?
So, it's 0.2 liters
of fruit juice.
I shouldn't even define M, we
know that M is equal to 2.
So ignore that.
You can tell I'm doing these
problems in real time.
I'm struggling with
them as you would.
Anyway, so how much fruit juice
is there going to be in
the mixture?
There's the amount of
liters of the pure
fruit juice she adds.
This is a pure fruit
juice, that's P.
And then you're going to have
the two liters of the mixture
that is 10% fruit juice.
So how much fruit juice
is coming from that?
Well 10% of two liters is
0.2 liters already.
And then how many liters
is there going
to be in the mixture?
In the combined, how many
total liters are there?
Well, there's the liters of the
pure fruit juice, plus the
two liters that we're
adding to.
This is the amount
of fruit juice.
This is a total amount
of liquid.
And we got the 0.2
from 10% times 2.
And we said that this
has to equal 25%.
We want this to be
25% of this.
So this should be 0.25.
That was an inadvertent
mark right down there.
So now we just solve for P.
The hard part is setting
up the problem.
So let's multiply P plus
2 times both sides.
So you get P plus 0.2 is equal
to 0.25 times this.
So 0.25P plus 0.25
times 2 is 0.5.
Fair enough.
Let's subtract 0.2
from both sides.
You get P is equal to 0.25P,
0.5 minus 0.2 is plus 0.3.
Let's subtract 0.25P
from both sides.
1P minus 0.25P is 0.75P
is equal to 0.3.
And let's see where this goes.
Did I do that right?
0.75P is equal to 0.3.
Right.
The decimals sometimes
get confusing.
So let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 10.
You get 7.5P is equal to 0.3.
Sorry, is equal to 3,
we multiplied by 10.
So you get P is equal
to 3 over 7.5.
How many times does
7.5 go into 3?
So that's the same thing
as how many times
does 75 go into 30.
Put a decimal sign.
Let's see, it goes into
it I think four times.
It's 0.4.
So P is equal to 0.4 liters.
We have to add 0.4 liters of
pure fruit juice to the two
liter mixture.
So you add 0.4 to the two liter
mixture, so you end up
with 0.6 liters of
pure fruit juice.
So the numerator becomes 0.6.
And the denominator
becomes 2.4.
Which, sure enough,
is 1/4 or 25%.
Fascinating problem.
Next question.
And these are good to learn.
A lot of times in math class
people are like, what do I
need to learn this for?
But this type of algebra,
you're going to
use it all the time.
Especially if you go into
any type of science or
engineering.
Or, for that matter, investing
or finance.
You're going to use these kind
of, boy can I figure this out
or not type of equations all
the time when you're mixing
things and figuring out margins
and all the rest.
OK, let's see.
Which relation is a function?
So I have a little bit of
a review of a function.
So a function is a relation
that maps from
a domain to a range.
I want to say from A to B.
Or we could say from the
domain to the range.
Where it takes one set of
numbers, which you call the
domain, and we have another
set of numbers.
And for every number here,
there's exactly one
number in the range.
And that's the key.
From here to here, there's
only one number.
Now two of these could
meet the same number.
But you can't have one number
here going to two separate
numbers there.
That's the key.
Here we have the same number.
You have a minus 2 here.
And you have a minus 2 here.
So that's like the
same number.
Let's say this is a minus 2.
That minus 2 is going
to a 6 and here it's
going to minus 2.
So you have the same
number going to
two different numbers.
And you can't have that
in a function.
For any given number in the
domain, you definitely get
only one in the range.
So A is not the answer.
Let's see, does this have
that same problem?
See every number is there
exactly once.
You have one minus 2, one 0,
one 1, one 2, so you're not
going to have that problem.
My suspicion is it's
already B.
C has the same problem.
4 goes to a bunch of
different numbers.
4 goes to 0, 4 goes to
1, so it's not C.
And then this defines
two values for 10.
So that doesn't work either.
So the answer is B.
Problem 78.
All right.
For which equation graphed
below, are all
the y values negative?
So if all the y values are
negative, we have to stay
below the x-axis.
This is where all the y values
are negative, right there.
So this one seems to work.
A seems to work.
Here, these aren't negative
y values.
These are positive y values.
I didn't even copy and
paste all these.
But I can already see that these
are positive y values.
So A was the answer.
I'm sorry, I ran out of space.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.
All of these y values,
they're all negative.
You're staying in the third
and fourth quadrant.
All right, next video.